[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pieces
we lost the target repeat task force x
has lost the target
damage argus 3 is taking heavy fire get
to parkridge asap
don't worry boss we got this hey boomer
lay down suppress and fire
keep it down
these are still ringing after that last
barney
what is that
for hangover
i believe i can translate
boomerang has a concussion
from the enemy you missed in our last
encounter
guess those teeth are sharper than your
eyes shark man
i never never missed never miss yeah
yeah we bloody no you never shut up
about it
before i have another
i get it
smooth
well
that should knock a few years off the
old sentence that's reminding me of
something
oh yeah
waller's stupid alpha target so we're
supposed to be killing again
[Music]
look it's superman the mighty superman
has just rescued that pilot what a show
off peter spandex
we're on a top secret assassination
mission
here no
so figure out who we're killing yet
did you ever think i felt like a
microphone like that there but we're
still staying free big things happen
every time we meet like attracting
shouldn't have done that shock